tout allait bien avec ma meilleure amie
et au final le belge j'ai rien senti
c'est qu'avec qui accusent leurs
meilleurs amis d'accord et vous vous
appliquez dans le dos et dans la jambe
ah ouais deux moutures est d'accord au
début vous avez un ressenti un sentiment
et comment vous avez comme vous l'avez
commence à s'engourdir ah oui oui
comment ça se fait ça commence à saissac
c
alors c'est bon c'est pas ses passes on
va dire il ya l'effet psychologique
alors si je ne le savais pas aussi la
piqûre sur le moment non vous l'avez
constaté seconde herman paris avait
senti un engourdissement oui c'est ça
alors on va dire si la personne a piqué
dans la jambe au niveau d'un air par
exemple ça peut entraîner une sorte de
décharge ou un engourdissement de la
jambe d'accord après il ya toujours
l'effet psychologique évidemment
notamment de si on voit d'autres
personnes à côté de soi qui ont été
piqués de panique de peur d'angoissé
genre peut aussi se baptiser un certain
nombre de pas d'inquiétude il ya donc là
vous c'est quoi comment vous avez su
vous avez été piqué alors commencé au
tout début je commence à avoir les gens
il était je voyais les personnes jeunes
gens tentaient de moins en moins et au
final b j'ai fait un malaise
j'ai été récupéré par les pompiers ils
me donnaient de l'eau est moins hydrater
et après ils m'ont mis sous et moi ils
m'ont fait aller sous la tente
et il y avait 50 minutes d'attentes ce
qui était énorme donc
j'ai ma meilleure amie elle a appelé mon
contrat et
[Musique]
le temps qu'il arrive mon corps il a
lâché je ressentais plus mon corps je
faisais je n'avais plus les moyens je
pouvais plus marcher
j'ai alors il faut il faut savoir
bourassa lors on peut pas dire
très attention alors parfois aussi on
peut suspecter des produits qui ne sont
pas des toxiques par exemple l'insuline
pourrait vendre hexion d'insuline pour y
faire baisser le taux de sucre glace en
lave faire ressentir ce malaise
d'hypoglycémie c'est possible c'est
pourquoi en fait lorsque l'on va aller à
l'hôpital il faut faire des analyses
poussées pas que toxicologiques mais
aussi rechercher d'autres substances
plus naturelle plus difficile à dix cas
détectés mais que l'on peut tout à fait
rechercher si elles sont exogènes alors
en fred vous êtes papa des arbousiers
tient aussi c'était comment cette soirée
laurent dit c'était infernal c'est à
dire c'est bon on a juste il faut parler
c'est juste une tranche à monter à
monter moi je veux venir la montée mois
vous allez voir ça va être tout fauteur
donc en fin de compte ça s'est passé que
déjà dès le début c'était déjà un manque
d'organisation
les gens c'est comme si c'était vers
vous là au pire entre et l'imaginaire
l'a imaginé la foule voilà qui sont
passés en dessous comme au stade de non
ils sont repassés en dessous des anglais
et aux nombreux de la sécurité civile et
on était devant pour rentrer il n'y a
pas de barrière quand il ya trop de
monde est maintenant bien dans le micro
on met des barrières pour avancer pour
que les gens ils soient pas trop
d'accord quant à ckoi y avait rien en
fait c'était tout le monde est entassé
les handicapés ils pouvaient même pas
passé en fauteuil roulant rien d'accord
il a fallu que et vous vous étiez là bas
alors on n'avait pas été appliquée bon
non non mais je suis parti avant
d'accord quand vous avez les deux filles
par la compagnie ma deuxième petit et on
est partant vous avez appris que votre
fille s'était fait piquer vous êtes
inquiétez-vous akbar oui surtout que là
elle a toujours les jambes engourdies
trt c'est incroyable quand ses portes
alors voilà j'ai que ces sales blancs
toujours des nouvelles et est ce que
vous êtes allé porter plainte traire le
salon important il faut porter plainte
ensuite est-ce que vous êtes allé voir
un médecin légiste donc aux urgences
médico-judiciaires c'est elle qui pourra
dire c'est pas moi voilà oui ils m'ont
interrogé
les policiers m'ont interrogé ils ont
pris ma plainte en france a dit à la
presse ag je suis passé à l'hôpital
direct c'est les pompiers qui sont venus
me chercher parce que mon cas je me
sentais partir voilà enfin bon j'ai ouï
je pouvais plus parler j'avais pas plus
rien il vaut mieux faire l'ordre inverse
c'est à dire porter plainte puis ensuite
aller
et si c'est n'est pas possible
un pas important ça peu importe le type
de prélèvement parce que si les
prélèvements sont faits par un
urgentiste non certifiés ça a moins de
valeur après ont annoncé les gendarmes
qui m'ont fait les prix les faits voilà
comme c'est fait par un médecin légiste
ou sur réquisition des forces de l'ordre
ou de l'officier de police judiciaire
qui ont là ça a une valeur qui va être
reconnue par le tribunal s'il ya une
plainte évident j'étais pas tout seul à
l'hôpital y avait plusieurs personnes
mais c'est pourquoi c'est important
aussi parce que nous faisons une
formation de l'ensemble des médecins
urgentistes a lentement pour savoir
faire les choses parce qu'un point
important par exemple c'est de ne pas
donner un anxiolytique la personne qui
vient parce qu'après ça pourrait fausser
évidemment les mécanismes n'ont rien
donné mais pourquoi pourquoi l'été elle
est tombée dans les pommes il n'y a pas
de produit saq échoue bah c'est ce que
je dis c'est dégueulasse je ne peux pas
dire évidemment sur les analyses très
poussées pourront le dire alors il ya
toujours la protection d'un produit
comme la possibilité comme je
l'expliquais de l'injection par exemple
d'insuline qui provoque une chute de la
maison quoi mais c'est sucré donc
c'est un produit quand même c'est
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de dire parce que c'est vrai que
vous êtes un père de famille vous avez
emmené vos deux fils house est dit
j'étais allé un spectacle on était comme
des fous et puis c'est la soirée sinon
c'est vraiment un cauchemar à sortir
c'est un problème les festivités l'été
c'est tout valeur à vivre il va y avoir
de problème à ce problème donc là ça
vous fait flipper ou dit ouais ouais je
le vois je le vois je te sens
bah ouais je vais pas raconter
l'histoire je te sens bien précis c'est
gratuit et y avait treize mille
personnes qui pouvaient aller et venir
librement plus de 3000 personnes qui
attendaient dehors donc là c'était très
compliqué on était 20000 toi là autant
et ce qui est paradoxal c'est que là ils
ont poussé des micros
[Applaudissements]
encore sûr
la raison ils n'y croient ils sont en
voyant les
fêtes c'est que beaucoup de gens
s'accordent à dire qu'il n'y avait rien
dans ces seringue mais vous quand on
vous écoute on achète sur deux vous êtes
fait injecter un liquide toxique c'est
ça c'est quoi votre théorie après si
c'est juste une piqûre c'est une piqûre
marais c'est toujours un rôle ou trop
tard
vous poser une question inélégant ps que
par ailleurs vous avez vu où vous avez
pris ne savent pas tu ne sois pas là
parce que les unités tout à l'heure elle
doit pas
s'arrêter parce que le docteur disais
tout à l'heure il y avait aussi pas mal
de jeunes on sait que c'est fait
le manque d'eau tout ça je veux bien
mais le soir et un manque d'eau dernière
question du monde sait que ce sont des
défis des build entre jeunes je crois me
oui je crois qu'il serait intéressant
que les jeunes entrent se dénonce ou 10
parce qu'à chaque fois maintenant c'est
tous les soirs il n'y a pas que dans
cette soirée c'est partout c'est arrivé
de 5n aussi tout ça arrive tout le temps
et ça va arriver avant la vie de plus en
plus c'est quoi je suis d'accord il par
contre je crois que commencer par dont
je termine si tu mets au calme toi sur
les réseaux sociaux je crois qu'il faut
le dire dès que ça sort de prévenir la
police effectivement ça a été pas ce que
dit le médecin sérieux vous c'était sur
rfm
avec eddy mitchell merci les a pas été
pris au sérieux il n'a calé poster des
choses sur la boucherie ouais bah je
sais pas mais parfois conneries
bah oui c'est vrai dans tout cas moi je
pense qu'il y paraît que je dis quand je
dis non mais il paraît que jeudi à une
personne qui s'est fait piquer nom et
qu'elle est revenue le vendredi c'est
vrai vous habituer commission n'était
pas un gars qui voulait faire ces
vaccins c'est ce que j'ai pensé aussi
aux concerts de johnny n'y a pas eu et à
la magnifique djoudi incroyable contre
bobby moore et ses fermes et basses et
fermé bah ouais bah voilà